danke an alle unsere vorfahren die seit
16 117 ihre energie und ihr engagement
für dich gegeben haben und jetzt
hoffentlich verstehen dass wir 2020
nicht nach was können und wollen
die befreundeten bäcker bvr ein
es ist zeit unsere brauereien lebewohl
zu sagen und das möchten wir hiermit in
form eines symbolischen blieb ist tun
liebl annika bier brauereien vielen dank
dass wdr.de hatten sich in der fünften
beziehungsweise sechsten generation
leiten zu dürfen
nach mittlerweile über 400 jahren seines
bestehens wissen wir was das bedeutet
viele viele brauereien der regionen
haben wir geht nicht bis hierher
geschafft
gemeinsam mit unserem team das zum teil
aus mitarbeitern besteht die länger hier
arbeiten als mein bruder und ich auf der
welt sind und man zieht das ist schon
wirklich lange aber wir es bis hierher
geschafft
nicht immer war der weg einfach es galt
viele krisen und herausforderungen zu
meistern
an den generationen haben gekämpft und
auch wir haben immer wieder sowohl
geschäftlich als auch privat in krisen
dafür gesorgt dass alle mitarbeiter ihre
löhne erhalten dass alle lieferanten
bezahlt werden und dass die kunden einem
das produkt erhalten
wir sind stolz dass wir es bis hierher
geschafft haben aber dennoch hat uns der
weg unheimlich viel kraft gekostet
juni wird brauerei ist immer
allgegenwärtig du bist immer
gesprächsthema nummer eins unserer
familie
du bist immer präsent bei jedem essen
jedem gedanken du bist es für die wir
nicht nur die normale arbeitszeit im
büro leisten sondern für die wir auch im
abend- und wochenendveranstaltungen
unternehmen ermöglicht haben und für die
wir immer wieder auf möglichst jede
veranstaltung und in jeder schritte
gegangen sind
egal ob das im feierabend - war oder
geschäftlich wir haben für deinen kunden
immer ein offenes ohr gehabt und unser
bestes gegeben und wir müssen an dieser
stelle auch betonen dass du ganz ganz
tolle kunden hast die uns über rund zehn
jahre die treue gehalten haben und die
wussten das zu einer guten
geschäftsbeziehung immer geben und
nehmen gehört eine branche ist
unheimlich hat die bierpreise sind
schwierig und es strengt an dass wir mit
einkaufszentrale über zwei cent am
kasten rauf oder runter behandeln müssen
obwohl mir jeden cent gebrauchen könnten
dennoch konnten wir in den letzten drei
jahren mit wirklich richtig viel mühe
und kampf positive betriebsergebnisse
verzeichnen und somit weiter investieren
und mitarbeiter löhne erhöhen
nun stehen wir abermals vor einer
unheimlich großen herausforderungen der
kongress hat dafür gesorgt dass alle
veranstaltungen die an stehen unter
anderem auch außerordentlich viele große
zeltfeste bereits abgesagt wurden oder
vermutlich noch abgesagt werden
der kameruner hier muss tritt unsere
gastronomie konnten
von dem wir sehr viele haben richtig
hart zahlreiche gastronomen haben
bereits im vorfeld massive probleme denn
auch deren branche ist keine leichte
mehr
es wird leider einige betriebe geben die
nicht wieder öffnen werden dh zu den
bereits in den letzten jahren immer
steigendem schließungen im rahmen des
gastronomie stabes kommen noch viele
weitere hinzu liebe bereich wir können
uns diesem kampf aber mal stellen
wir können versuchen mit allen mitteln
auf geschäftlicher und privater ebene
diese krise zu meistern
aber wir sind so müde wie sind so
unfassbar müde von den vielen kämpfen
der letzten jahre
du liebe brauereien du hast uns alles
abverlangt
über anderen geschäftlichen bereich wir
als familie sind mehr als noch einmal an
unseren persönlichen grenzen gekommen
oder ganz einfach wir müssen dir deshalb
mitteilen dass es zeit von uns von dir
zu verabschieden
du kannst uns glauben dass diese
entscheidung die mit abstand schwerste
und tränenreiche entscheidung ist die
welt jemals gefällt haben
es bricht uns das herz aber wir haben
uns entschieden dass unsere
herausforderung nicht nur der korona
kampf an sich sondern auch deine
betriebs auflösung sein wird da viel
investiert die energie der letzten
haben wir die chance diese auflösung
völlig frei von banken und
insolvenzverwalter zu führen wir können
dich liebe brauerei ganz in ruhe als
familien so wie du es verdient hast
schließen
wir werden das geschäft zum 30.09
einstellen
bis dahin hoffen ihnen von herzen auch
die neue lied ende kunden denn wir haben
noch viel bier in flaschen versammlungen
tanz und wünschen uns dass dieses noch
seinen weg zu all den freunden und
kunden nicht nach abschluss landet liebe
brauereien wir hoffen so sehr dass die
alle kunden und mitarbeiter bis zum ende
noch zur seite stehen werden
corona für die größte herausforderung
seit vielen vielen jahren vor allem
privat fassungen und mittelständischen
betriebe unseres landes seiner
schließung sind die größte
herausforderung für unsere familie
danke an alle unsere vorfahren die seit
16 117 ihre energie und ihr engagement
für dich gegeben haben und jetzt
hoffentlich verstehen dass wir 2020
nicht mehr was sie können und wollen
dass ich für die er raten sich zu lassen
da hilft dass wir gegen die es offene
fabelhafte mitarbeiter kennenlernen
durften damit dass wir alle deine liebe
und treue kunden betreuen dürfen
du bist im laufe der nächsten jahre
nicht mehr unsere gesprächsthema nummer
eins bleiben aber du bist unser
emotionalste und lang an
zur erinnerung sein im liebe und trauer
deine vermieden gelangen